it is two years and you join us here in
staffordshire at this national memorial
arboretum where traditionally over the
years britain's military sacrifices have
been remembered today is all about
reflecting on what has happened over the
past two years and paying tribute to the
work of the national health service
staff who have gone above and beyond
in britain's hospitals over the past two
years so this small event this morning
and put together by nhs charities
together i spoke to their chief exec
ellie orton earlier on and she spoke
quite movingly of her immense pride in
all sectors of the nhs and the
incredible work that they have done over
the course of the past two years so
there will be a minute silence coming up
and then we will hear various different
dignitaries speaking and there will be a
performance by the birmingham women and
children's choir so we'll pause now um
to reflect on the past two years and
that minute silence just coming up now
signal the beginning of a minute silence
which will conclude with a performance
from our tenor rhys marion singing nella
fantasia
our inspiring and honouring
contributions
will then be introduced by rihanna and
rakesh
co-chaplains of birmingham women's and
children's multi-faith and belief
chaplaincy team
who themselves have been supporting
bereaved families and colleagues of nhs
staff
during the past
two years
let us take a moment
to prepare for our one minute silence
so
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
or
[Music]
god
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now earlier on i spoke to
flis pass who is a nurse at the queen's
hospital in barton here in staffordshire
and she pointed out that there are still
10 000 people in hospitals across the
united kingdom with covert 19 and in her
words this pandemic is far from over
this morning's service here and
remembering the extraordinary work and
sacrifice of all sectors of the national
health service over the course of the
past two years of this pandemic
ender thank you